over the weekend Chris the big news was
as of Saturday the president had a
conference call with Sports
Commissioners and I thought it was
interesting that two of the
commissioners on the call were UFC
president Dana White and WWE owner Vince
McMahon because those two institutions I
don't know that they're leagues I don't
know what they are especially WWE they
are continuing to have events they are
continuing to do things yes there are no
fans present but right on the clip of
Rob Gronkowski becoming the new 24/7 WWE
Champion there's no social distancing
going on at WrestleMania last night it
was a scrum of bodies just beating the
crap out of each other as Rob Gronkowski
jumped and landed on top of them so I
think the involvement of those two guys
I think part of that was a subtle push
to the rest of them like let's find a
way to get back to somewhat normal let's
find a way to get back to doing the
things you do even if no fans are
present and the president reportedly
said during the call that he believes
the NFL season should start on time and
look I at this point no one knows how
this is gonna play out as I saw many
people say the virus is gonna dictate
the schedule no one else and until
there's a vaccine it's gonna be very
difficult to envision full stadiums now
is there a way to work it out and make
it happen
without full stadiums well we're seeing
it with UFC and we're seeing with WWE
and again that's why I think those guys
were on the call the message is find a
way there's a cash incentive as it
relates to televising these events and
there's a public incentive to just
create things for the millions of people
who are at home and who are complying as
best they can with stay at home orders
it's just something else to pass the
time so the more of these events that
that return the easier not a lot easier
but at least a little bit easier it's
gonna be for the folks who are trying to
get through the the stay at home
requirements yeah well I mean I
appreciate the optimism from President
Trump and and yeah I mean we know he's
friends with Dana White Dana White's
been doing things as far as trying to
stay aggressive with the UFC
you know I'm optimistic too as you are
but you're right I mean there's just too
many things right now that are just
there's no answer to
you know I don't know you know again I
hope we do yes selfishly you know for
all of us I think we'll need the
entertainment by that time by that time
that time rolls around for us let alone
it probably has some benefits to the
economy and listen I'm not smart enough
to go down that road but I certainly
would think it would with televised live
events and commercials and everything
else to get things going but you know
Mike we talked about this a little last
week you know it's just going to take
unless there is a vaccination or
something like that you know if the New
York Giants end up getting into week one
and then find out somebody has copa90
know their football team I just don't
know what the process will be right then
or maybe before the season starts during
training camp even though a team is
trying to do the best to have their team
and players and coaches on lockdown and
separated from society you know what if
there is that one asymptomatic guy in
the locker room who didn't know he had
it and now he's passed it around the
locker room to a bunch of teams you know
do they not play their game the next
week there's just so much unknown right
now we're hopeful but you know I don't
think we can predict anything at this
point
and one thing that many believe will
happen by September the ability to do a
quick and simple test for whether or not
someone currently has coronavirus
whether yet someone has the antibodies
that show they've already had it so
they're fine I mean those are little
things and I'm picking up and let me
tell you this in this that I am NOT
contractually required to say this but
NBC Nightly News with Lester Holt and
over the weekends with Kate snow has
become indispensable viewing for me and
for my family because you know you could
drive yourself crazy with this stuff all
day long or you can take a half hour
that has everything you need to know
jammed into it and Jerry weeknight 6:30
p.m. Eastern that's where I pick things
up and I picked that up last night how
quickly they're developing these tests
where you can get a quick idea as to
whether or not it's safe or not safe for
you to be exposed to a certain
environment they're using it for health
care work
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports